[Music]
in worse toilet ever news
where's toilet yeah right when you're
talking about it submitted by bacon a
new toilet design makes workers
uncomfortable taking long bathroom
breaks I saw this it's like angled
slightly comfortably monsters oh my god
we need to set our house cause Bart
takes forever don't you take the minimum
30 minutes no you don't watch it hey has
it changed since you had a kid yeah it's
probably closer now he's hiding
sanctuary huh I've heard of I've heard
of I think only poop for like 10 minutes
at the most
you so much Steve Steve's like I'll be
ready in five minutes and then an hour
goes by am i wet are you doing that is
old Steve how does it take you longer
than 5 min after the rest like that kind
of spokesperson on TV right now good
thing you're an Iceman because you need
some ice for that burn you set yourself
up for failure you come back to me you
come back to me what was your point what
you make they take you longer than 5
minutes yes okay so when me and Nicky
got together I used to have acne not so
fun here comes the substance no true I
used to take a longer time in the
bathroom back in the day what are you
doing with your [ __ ] acne toes that's
funny but I was trying to cover it up oh
you wore makeup because I used to be in
videos a lot and we'd shoot log and
stuff and so I was doing drivers cover
and chill yeah I don't take that long in
the bathroom now or any time though and
how long does it take you put on
concealer for you it takes I didn't know
how to do it nobody ever taught me yeah
we don't have all the experience girls
huh no one ever taught us we don't
forget come out of the womb no exactly
I've got like 10 15 years of experience
of doing it right I mean how much female
privilege cuz you possibly have you have
every single person who's your friend
could teach you how to do this [ __ ]
every single possible privilege I like
how you was so well had friends growing
up I do yes I mean how many times have I
been like I'll take a five-minute shower
really hard he's kind of sputtering a
bit this is an old game about me that is
not in there but and it's all meme about
me even for 30 minutes no you got it all
you gotta own your meme no no I own all
means but only curb memes yes I don't
use old me nuts he's not owning this not
only erroneous meme the only old me
might use at the Robert Redford one
we're here nods like that what are the
current means he doesn't drink water oh
yeah you don't drink water that's true
oh yeah there's none on that side
current memes are yeah I don't drink
water tequila Rockstar and Diet Coke
going on oh man sriracha thank you all
of these things means everybody turn me
mouthwash pretty clean though we're
looking Ryan what a [ __ ] lush go look
man I was given this by my good friend
Steve green well I heard that markers
anyway have water on this thing talking
about a toilet yeah and this toilets is
by this company named standard toilet
and they created this seat that is
angled at its it's at a forward angle a
13 degrees slide off 13 degree angle oh
[ __ ]
doesn't really seem like the standard so
they're saying is that it's not that
it's not uncomfortable or anything when
you initially sit on it but it's meant
for you to not be comfortable enough to
sit on it longer than five minutes
longer than five minutes that sounds
like a challenge you have a stomach flu
or something that's what people are
saying yeah what are you taking the real
shitty or like so
try to market this joint employers and
like public restrooms so they're trying
to do it if you were really trying to
get away though you just stand like what
the [ __ ] like she wouldn't just wouldn't
sit on it exactly but then they're also
saying that this is like discriminatory
against people that have disabilities or
people that have you know like just
humans don't work like black and white
like clockwork like our bodies aren't
standard they are not um we're all
Amazon employees dude right so they're
saying that you know other people can be
urinating and defecating in ways that
require a standard toilet regular toilet
not this Dan just think that like if you
have to invest that much of your
thinking time to like get a different
toilet for your employees like hire
better employees like hire people that
want to work through them yeah but you
can't you can't fire somebody cuz we're
taking too long in the bathroom Canyon I
don't know if they're taking too much
time out of workplace discrimination
should you be excessively on the toilet
like like if you're not getting your
work done and it's sort of like well
yeah you should know yeah hmm I don't
think they could fire you because you
were in the bathroom till I think they
would fire you because you didn't get
your work done
I see which could be Titan to me Alabama
yeah although that sounds to get you I
would like to see this toilet and see if
I could see how long it sit on it for
yeah I don't know I feel like cuz I if I
have all the toilet for too long my legs
go to sleep my tea - yeah imagine an
angle really no I'm okay I hate even
sitting on it totally just the monsters
that decided to design this toilet like
let's market to employers to torture
their employees that have to poop a lot
do you think they were they were talking
with the HR department they're all just
sitting there just twiddling their
Mustang spikes extreme what if we slowly
burns
but only after five minutes those little
employees won't like that
remember what we reported that other
bathroom what the water jug it was like
aunty homeless people it was the one
where it would pretty much like eject
someone or Jonas Cruise is it like you
have to say you're at dry your home
address
out loud and then if you're homeless you
don't have one and then you they kick
you up practically cuz it was aimed for
people that are homeless so they won't
be like spending the night in the toilet
and all that or in the restroom I forgot
what it was but anyway it was like water
jets that was like great you know the
guys like cuz like one five two five
extra street and they're like that is
not a real address and they started
[ __ ] batting them out with upper room
okay no I think it's to prevent two
people from using so like to prevent
like sexual assault like I think that's
what it was alarm would go off to people
there we're fun recipe how do we limit
or sometimes just really fat get the
rape alerted no I would never have a
desk cuz C will have sex with me in a
public restrooms I want to wow that's
new you want to I want to do it what are
the current memes these very urban oh
and eukaryote means you never nude
they're made good job but yeah what do
you mean you want to I can't you yeah
why can't you what stop in the moment
hasn't arisen exactly
yours are already half naked those
bathrooms that's true floors what no
what about the casino bathrooms oh those
were really nice yeah also busy
not really it's never happening the
threshold for Nikki he'll receive no
busier people wanted to gamble more than
they wanted to go to the bathroom I need
a vacant vacant bathroom pre-baby so
specific to the bathroom like I found
one we're like we could lock the door
and stuff he's like it's too dirty no
Lily smelled like poop like I took like
a bathroom well right but now all that
is like who you were going to the
Cheesecake Factory
OOP it smells like like toilet cleaner
breathe through your muffin they're
doing it ahh you can taste it tastes
like cheesecake factory bathrooms are so
[ __ ] clean you could lick the wall
yeah now you have your bath yeah he's
already ten Nordstrom what does it say
oh yeah yeah and those doors go from the
ceiling to the floor I wouldn't just
[ __ ] in the Nordstrom's bathroom I would
take my entire family into the dirty man
what about what about changing rooms coz
there's no toilet even in there well she
wants a bathroom we want a bath mr.
speaker
I don't care if it's a changing room but
I don't want a mom or mom what that
wants to breasts for you coming in and
be like cocoa recipe down the open in
public because it's never wrong to
breastfeed he said the other part mouth
[ __ ] love women it'll go away
genuine thank you your side thank you
I know the perfect solution for these
toilets you just have to sit on your
hands bring a little wedge for both your
yeah we're like a squatty potty kind of
a bar top to little doorstop
you could probably 3d print something
too for some company invent something
for the employees as the same company
actually the measurements like it's like
an arms deal you deal to both sides
[Applause]
yeah I wonder what other things these
[ __ ] evil people will come up with
then for the bathroom what kind of sink
can you create that was just ruined
people water's either actually my right
should we call those have you ever had
this one sink where it it's like the
sink is like okay this is the whole
thing of a sink right like this big and
then the [ __ ] faucet is right [ __ ]
hey like get the water like go in friend
you BAM you smack your head oh it's like
why do you have all of this it's one of
these contemporary sinks it's like a
perfect like ball right is that perfect
ball right and then the way the faucet
points it makes it a perfect half pipe
so when you turn it on it first goes
like this splashes into you and you
don't even know like the lose its bucket
leg like spout that's like just a square
it comes on just shoots at your chest I
hate the ones that are the flat that
they're just there for the scratch the
flat the square
but they like this ran flat and they
turn on the water and it just like
bounces up there punishment sinks what
tip has four dozen those are good
punishment sinks then like Barmes and
that I think work gets really hot or
really cold on yeah or you could have a
sink that just yells racist [ __ ] at you
how does it know the race you are o yell
Mexican slurs at me I'm not even gonna
know how about this the sink can smell
you know you're a I don't know your
worries your hmm sounds expensive come
true but worth it but you can always
smell a race that's what I think
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]